The creatures in The Witcher might've come
from myths and legends, but they don't look
exactly like their traditional counterparts.
They don't act quite like them either.
These are the stories that inspired some of
The Witcher's most fearsome beasts.
Netflix's The Witcher opens with a swampy
duel between Geralt of Rivia and the kikimora,
a hulking spider-like creature with an unsettlingly
human head.
While Geralt makes quick work of the beast,
the kikimora ends up getting the last laugh.
Despite the kikimora's ferocity, no one is
willing to pay Geralt for its corpse, making
all his effort futile.
While the kikimora battle makes for a great
opening set piece, The Witcher's version of
the creature, both in the series and in the
games, is a very liberal take on the kikimora
legend.
In Slavic mythology, a kikimora is a house
spirit that sneaks into your home via your
keyhole in order to deliver bad news.
Once a kikimora settles in, it can also cause
nightmares, sleep paralysis, and nighttime
calamities like dying cattle and spoiled food.
Don't ever look directly at a kikimora, either
do so, and you might die.
Instead of a multi-legged monstrosity, a kikimora
typically looks like a mix between an old
woman and a bird, complete with a beak and
chicken legs and a headscarf wrapped around
her stringy hair.
Unlike Geralt, you typically don't kill them
with a sword, either.
Just leave some food behind the stove, where
kikimory live.
According to some legends, that'll do the
trick.
The striga is Geralt's foe in episode three
of the series, "Betrayer Moon," and "The Witcher,"
Andrzej Sapkowski's very first witcher story.
On Netflix's The Witcher, the striga looks
like a giant humanoid monster, complete with
a long, dangling umbilical cord.
In Polish folklore, the "strzyga" is no less
dangerous, but it does work a little differently.
Strzygi were said to be people born with two
souls, and who could be identified by their
twin hearts or extra pairs of teeth.
When a baby was born that people suspected
was a strzyga, they were banished.
Then, one of their souls died and they became
monsters, often with feathers and blue or
grey skin, who transformed into owls to suck
the blood of their victims.
The strzyga is one of the most dangerous creatures
in Polish folklore, and it's not easy to get
rid of them.
Some people claim that cutting off a strzyga's
head and burying it far away from the body
will get the job done, although burying one
face-down with a sickle around its neck is
said to work, too.
The Witcher's fourth episode, "Of Banquets,
Bastards and Burials," is based on the Brothers
Grimm story "Hans My Hedgehog."
In that story, a child named Hans is born
with the legs of a human, but the body and
head of a hedgehog.
Years after his family casts him out, Hans
runs across two lost kings in the forest.
Hans offers to help them find their way, but
for a price: each ruler needs to give Hans
"the first thing that greets [the king] at
the royal court upon his arrival home."
That ends up being the princess, meaning Hans
gets a beautiful wife for his trouble.
Hans and Duny, the cursed knight in The Witcher,
differ in a few subtle ways.
While Duny is as big as a man, Hans is more
hedgehog-sized.
He rides a rooster like a horse, and is often
mistaken for an animal.
Further, Duny simply transforms into a human.
Hans' shift is a lot more gruesome: not only
does he physically shed his hedgehog skin,
but after throwing it into the fire, his new,
human skin is charred black, requiring the
aid of the local healer.
The dryads of Brokilon Forest don't mess around.
Forced into hiding by humans and monsters,
they fearsomely protect their land from intruders.
They shoot Ciri's friend, Dara, before he
can even reach the woods.
They force all newcomers to drink the water
of Brokilon, which kills anyone who harbors
ill-will against the forest, and makes anyone
who doesn't slowly forget their past.
Accordingly, The Witcher's dryads dress in
armor and heavy makeup.
They're imposing figures, as they should be,
and they resolutely stand their ground.
That's a big departure from the dryads of
Greek mythology, where the creatures originated.
In the original myths, dryads or nymphs who
were tied to forests or trees were actually
known for being exceptionally shy.
They didn't really fight, although some of
them could transform from human-like creatures
into trees.
For the most part, dryads are passive figures
in the Greek myths.
It was up to The Witcher to give them some
grit.
"Please, don't hurt me!"
In "Rare Species," Geralt and Jaskier join
a group of warriors who are competing to see
who can kill a dragon first.
Not only is the hunt that ensues is full of
twists and turns, but it's a big part of The
Witcher's behind-the-scenes history: The story
that the episode is based on, "The Bounds
of Reason," is an adaptation of the Polish
folktale that inspired Sapkowski to create
Geralt in the first place.
The story of the Wawel Dragon dates back to
the 13th century, and while it takes many
forms, some elements are always the same.
There's always a king whose subjects are terrorized
by a man-eating, cattle-devouring dragon.
There are always brave knights who try to
conquer the dragon in hopes of winning the
princess' hand.
They always fail.
Finally, there's always a hero, usually depicted
as a cobbler, who decides to use the dragon's
own appetite against him.
The cobbler fills a sheepskin with hay and
sulfur, then waits for the dragon to eat it.
That makes the dragon so thirsty that it drinks
water until it literally explodes.
It's one of Poland's most beloved stories
there's even a seven-headed statue commemorating
the dragon in Krakow but Sapkowski thought
it was ridiculous.
You wouldn't call a cobbler to kill a dragon,
he figured.
You'd call a professional.
And so, the author invented a fictional monster
hunter, and lo and behold, Geralt of Rivia
was born.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Witcher
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.